[Music]
so let me tell you something yes sir
I just want to keep people on since
that's only a few months before said
passed away it was only for five months
I was visiting him up at the top of the
hill where he lived and he looked at me
and he said Mel Brooks
Mel Brooks what a career what a career
you went from me to Hitler still
glorious you know you know it's it's he
was such an incredible guy you know what
I wanted to do and it's the Irish
tradition is when someone passes away
and I don't know what what Jewish people
do but Irish people we tell stories we
reminisce we laugh I need eight potatoes
and get drunk we don't wait till someone
dies to do that but i but i but I really
wanted to as you know since these are
meant so much to me and you mean so much
to me and the idea of you coming here
and just talking I'm here because you
were so damn nice when young when you
found out that he was gone and you said
she really took some time and said
lovely things and heartfelt things and I
was really you know I was I was touched
by and I said I would like to celebrate
his life with you you know if it's
possible to work you know it's funny
except one of my goals is to show his
work which is so funny to younger people
who might not be familiar with it and he
was such a fantastic performer as you
know he was big guy he was a powerful
guy but he could do he could double talk
in any language he didn't know the
language right but he could pretend that
he knew German or Italian or pretty much
or French or any language and convince
people that he knew it oh absolutely we
were in France once the teet Ryan did he
do that French double-talk with people
he did he said
busca for the idea of occlusion for
chosen and the waiter new daddy there
was some French there but he couldn't
make any sense out of it you're right
right he kept saying I don't lay and
took the took English I take your order
and Syd Syd was relentless you know I'm
gonna fold it up at three I mean people
were getting up and saluting I mean yeah
yeah it was insane there was a great
sketch that I believe you wrote this
sketch the german general yes you wrote
this sketch and i want to show some of
it now where Sid gets to show and he's
with the great Howie Morris and they're
both showing this great ability but
especially SID to to sound like he's
speaking fluent German and it's complete
BS
[Music]
[Music]
- Nick Martin drachma so big with the
Ulta claim must be filled out the
Gladers
but he also see that Misha Unger tunic
button turning button no - Nick Martin
air
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it's you know as standings the
ending of a sketch is the hardest thing
in the world it was such a fantastic one
of my favorite endings of a sketch of
all time yeah just a brushstroke of
pathos you knows now he was a big German
General and but I stole it from a mill
Jennings and the last laugh I mean you
have to know where to steal things from
you know we're gonna take a quick break
much more break yeah
[Applause]